sie existieren vielleicht nur für eine
sekunde für uns beobachter dauert diese
sekunde aber ja milliarden jahre
schwarze löcher
jetzt wurde ein gigantisches
schwerkraftmonster direkt in unserer
kosmischen nachbarschaft entdeckt es
befindet sich in einem zweifach
sternensystem und verhält sich wirklich
sonderbar kann es uns möglicherweise
gefährlich werden kriegs um
science-fiction
hier gibt es drei mal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen klick so gibt es jetzt
übrigens auch als podcast für unterwegs
die links zu apple und spotify sind
unten in der video beschreibung es ist
ein echter zufallsfund aber dafür nicht
weniger spektakulär
das sternsystem ist schon länger bekannt
aber dass darin ein schwarzes loch
verborgen ist eigentlich hatte das
internationale forschungsteam mit hilfe
des mpg eso zeitpunkt zwei meter
teleskops am la silla in chile doppelt
sterne zu beobachten doch dabei machten
die forschenden eine seltsame entdeckung
das sternsystem hr 68 19
denn der innere der beiden sterne dreht
sich um ein drittes objekt und braucht
40 tage um dieses einmal zu umrunden der
äußere stern dagegen dreht sich in einem
weiten orbit um beide inneren objekte
doch was bildet das zentrum des systems
ein großes rätsel
das auch mit hilfe des teleskops nicht
gelüftet werden konnte
doch die umlaufbahn des inneren sterns
gibt hinweise darauf dass das zentrum
mindestens viermal so schwer sein muss
wie unsere sonne und das lässt nur den
einen rückschluss zu da sind sich die
fachleute absolut sicher bei diesem
unsichtbaren objekt mit der mindestens
vierfachen sonnenmasse kann es sich nur
um eines handeln um ein schwarzes loch
denn alles was so schwer ist fällt durch
die eigene gravitation in sich zusammen
zu einem schwarzen loch und das verhält
sich auf eine ganz besondere art und
weise die grundlegenden daten dieses
schwerkraftmonster ist rund 1000
lichtjahre von uns entfernt in der
astronomie ist das ziemlich nahe in
einer klaren nacht ist es sogar möglich
das sternsystem mit dem bloßen auge zu
erkennen möglich ist das von der
südhalbkugel aus das system hr 68 19
befindet sich im sternbild teleskop die
um die beiden sterne selbst sind
tatsächlich in einer dunklen nach
ohne fernglas oder teleskop zu sehen nur
das schwarze loch das kann man halt
nicht erspähen auch nicht mit einem
teleskop oder fernglas dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam in der aktuellen studie
wir waren völlig überrascht als wir
feststellten dass dies das erste
sternsystem mit einem schwarzen loch ist
dass man mit bloßem auge sehen kann
dieses system enthält das der erde
nächstgelegene schwarze loch von dem wir
wissen es handelt sich also um das
nächstgelegene schwarze loch das bislang
jemals aufgespürt werden konnte und das
obwohl uns eine distanz von 1000
lichtjahren trend im wirklich
unvorstellbar großen weltall ist diese
strecke aber wirklich minimal umfasst
gerade einmal unsere erweiterten
nachbarschaft das wird sehr gut deutlich
im vergleich mit dem supermassereichen
schwarzen loch namens sagittarius stern
das im zentrum der milchstraße
schlummert die entfernung zur erde
beträgt in diesem fall
ganze 26 tausend lichtjahre und es
enthält millionen von sonnenmassen
solche kolosse bin sich tatsächlich nur
im herzen von galaxien doch wie viele
stellare schwarze löcher also schwarze
löcher mit nur wenigen sonnenmassen gibt
es eigentlich da draußen hochrechnungen
lassen auf hunderte millionen stellare
schwarze löcher schließen die alle aus
dem kollaps großer sterne entstanden
sind
doch die suche nach ihnen gestaltet sich
ziemlich schwierig bis dann konnten
astronomie teams lediglich ein paar
dutzend dieser exemplare aufspüren das
ist auch nicht verwunderlich denn
schwarze löcher sind schlicht und
ergreifend unsichtbar
dabei gibt es nur eine ausnahme denn
wenn die masse giganten staub und gas
von einem stern ansaugen der ihm
besonders nahe ist verraten sich die
schwarzen löcher
denn hierbei legen sie ihr umfeld zum
leuchten an und genau so konnten
fachleute weltweit auch die bislang
bekannten stellaren schwarzen löcher aus
spüren so passiert das auch beim
schwerkraftmonster dass sich im stern
system zyklus x1 befindet etwa 6000
lichtjahre von uns entfernt
doch ihr nachweis funktioniert eben auch
über einen anderen weg den schwarze
löcher haben einfluss darauf wie sich
benachbarte sterne bewegen genauso
gelang auch eben die aktuelle entdeckung
durch die periodische verschiebung der
spektrallinien gelang es die bahnen der
beiden sterne den hr 6 819 herzuleiten
doch neben diesen kleineren stellaren
löchern die im schnitt nur etwa zehn mal
so schwer sind wie unsere sonne
gibt es einen weiteren typen die
supermassereichen schwarzen löcher eben
wie sagittarius stern im zentrum unserer
milchstraße über deren positionen und
bewegungen wissen fachleute weltweit
ziemlich gut bescheid er ist im frühling
diesen jahres gab es rund ein jahr nach
dem ersten foto eines schwarzen loches
gelang ein weiteres spektakuläres bild
jetzt zeigt materie die dem schwarzen
loch nur knapp entkommen ist die
hochauflösenden aufnahmen zeigen so
genannte jets die durch die
gravitationskräfte eines schwarzen lochs
ausgelöst werden und das ist ein
ziemlich spannendes phänomen denn
entgegen aller annahmen stoßen schwarze
löcher auch materie aus nicht aus ihrem
inneren aber die wirklich dramatischen
vorgänge um sie herum haben spektakuläre
folgen die sogenannten akkretionsscheibe
des schwarzen lochs rotiert rasend
schnell um dessen zentrum genau hier
sammelt sich materie bevor sie in das
zentrum eines schwarzen lochs kurz zuvor
heißt sie sich durch die
unterschiedliche geschwindigkeit der
teilchen in der akkretionsscheibe auf
die reiben sich außen sind sie langsamer
als in die scheibe beginnt zu strahlen
und ein kleiner teil der materie in der
akkretionsscheibe der wird gar nicht vom
schwarzen loch verschlungen stattdessen
wird er in form zweier starker
gebündelter plasma strahlen ins all
hinaus geschleudert und zwar senkrecht
zur scheibe und mit nahezu
lichtgeschwindigkeit die teilchen
verlassen also die akkretionsscheibe
nach oben und unten und treffen oberhalb
und unterhalb des schwarzen lochs
zusammen genau dort bilden sie die
sogenannten jets diese aufnahmen stammen
von dem casa mit der bezeichnung 1379
der unfassbare fünf milliarden
lichtjahre von uns entfernt ist somit
liegt dieses himmelsobjekt noch einmal
fast 100 mal weiter entfernt als das
schwarze loch der galaxie m87 dessen
aufnahme dem event horizon teleskop im
vergangenen jahr gelungen ist bei kasan
handelt es sich um die heißen und allen
zentren von sehr weit entfernten
galaxien und sie gehören mit zu den
leuchtkräftigen himmelsobjekten
überhaupt schon paradox schwarze löcher
sind mit die hellsten objekte im
universum eben wegen ihrer aggressions
schreiben ein passat 3c 279 leuchtet im
durchschnitt so hell wie viele millionen
sterne zusammen in ihrer mitte vermuten
astronomie teams supermassereiche
schwarze löcher die als nr
die quelle dienen und eben den effekt
erzeugen den ich geschrieben habe bei
dem fast 13 2 179 handelt es sich wohl
um ein schwarzes loch dessen masse
achtung eine milliarde mal so groß sein
dürfte wie die masse der sonne
das forschungsteam des event horizon der
des coups hatte sich ein trick zunutze
gemacht um an die spektakulären bilder
zu gelangen und zwar nutzen die
fachleute insgesamt acht teleskope an
verschiedenen orten der erde
diese werden mit hilfe einer speziellen
technik mit der bezeichnung very long
baseline interferometer miteinander
verbunden
obwohl sich forschungsteams weltweit
intensiv mit schwarzen löchern
beschäftigen gelten diese
schwerkraftmonster wohl noch immer als
die merkwürdigsten objekte im gesamten
universum immer wieder werden neue
spektakuläre entdeckungen gemacht denn
man darf nicht vergessen
durch die unglaubliche gravitation dort
jedes objekt das in das schwarze loch
gezogen wird kann es nicht mehr
verlassen die anziehungskraft ist so
stark dass es einfach alles aufsaugt
sogar licht wird verschlungen oft drehen
sie schwarze löcher mit annähernd
lichtgeschwindigkeit und genauso die
aktions scheiben um sie herum die folge
zeit und raum werden dort dramatisch
verzerrt von außen betrachtet ist der
raum dort zusammengequetscht und die
zeit läuft in zeitlupe ab sprich aus der
perspektive des schwarzen loches
existiert es vielleicht nur eine sekunde
für uns ja milliarden unglaubliche
relativistische effekte also effekte die
nur durch die relativitätstheorie
erklärt werden können und die
gravitation eines schwarzen loches ist
vermutlich so stark dass alles in der
mitte auf einen einzigen punkt
zusammengedrückt wird licht und materie
sind in dieser sogenannten singularität
gefangen und sie wirft einen schatten
den sogenannten ereignishorizont die
grenze hinter der alles verschwindet und
diesen punkt nicht mehr entfliehen kann
und auch wenn der kern eines schwarzen
loches immer unendlich klein sein dürfte
und der schatten wächst mit den dort in
diesem winzigen punkt gesammelten
teilchen immer weiter an und das erste
bild eines solchen schattens der sich
von der heißen akkretionsscheibe abhebt
wurde letztes jahr veröffentlicht
spektakulär und es gibt immer wieder
weiter neue erkenntnisse zu schwarzen
löchern us forschungsteam hat erst vor
kurzem ein extrem kleines schwarzes
auch aufgespürt das forschungsteam ist
sich sicher dass es sich um eine ganz
neue klasse von schwarzen löchern
handelt möglicherweise ist es also nur
eines von vielen die den forschern
bislang alle durch die lappen gegangen
sind bisher man nämlich davon aus dass
schwarze löcher mindestens die 5 fache
masse der sonne aufweisen die
forschenden appellieren jetzt die skala
der schwarzen löcher zu erweitern
dazu schreibt das forschungsteam in der
studie möglicherweise gibt es eine
population von ähnlich verborgenen
schwarzen löchern die durch die
bisherigen röntgen beobachtungen
übersehen wurden
doch es gibt viele weitere offene fragen
so wurden beispielsweise auch schon
einige schwarze löcher aufgespürt die
viel zu schwer sind um aus normalen
sternen entstanden zu sein wie also
kommt es zu solchen masse giganten
fachleute wissen dass solch ein masse
gigant niemals aus einem einzelnen
sternen kollaps hervorgehen könnte denn
dann hätte der entsprechendes stern
schon weit vor dem erreichen dieser
ausgangs masse kollabieren müssen ein os
forschungsteam hat sich dieses rätsel
genauer angeschaut und in einer
simulation analysiert und so ist es den
fachleuten tatsächlich gelungen die
entstehung dieser extremen masse
giganten zu erklären der neuen studie
zufolge fängt das umfeld von aktiven
galaxienkernen schwarze löcher ein und
lässt diese in serie miteinander
verschmelzen so kommt es zu der
außergewöhnlich großen masse dieser
objekte also achtung das sind keine
supermassiven oder supermassereichen
schwarzen löcher sondern einfach nur
außerhalb des galaxien kerns sehr sehr
schwere schwarze löcher mit der
vierfachen sonnenmasse ist das nun
entdeckte schwarze loch indirekter
erdnähe zwar nicht außergewöhnlich groß
doch es ist auf andere art und weise
sehr besonders macht seinem namen
tatsächlich alle ehre es ist schwarz und
unsichtbar also inaktiv und still ist
verspeist also derzeit keine materie aus
der umgebung anders als der großteil der
bislang entdeckten schwarzen löcher die
sich eben durch die helle
röntgenstrahlung verraten haben im
klartext heißt das also dass nun
entdeckte schwarze loch wurde lange
übersehen und das obwohl seine
begleitstern mit bloßem auge am himmel
sichtbar sind es handelt sich also nicht
nur um das nächste schwarze loch bislang
sondern auch um eines der ersten
schwarzen löcher die gefunden worden
sind mit stelara masse die nicht
gewaltsam mit ihrer umgebung in
agieren also sterne aufsaugen und daher
wirklich schwarz erscheinen aufgrund
dessen könnte die spektakuläre
entdeckung nach ansicht des astronomie
teams also nur die zitat spitze des
eisbergs sein möglicherweise existieren
in unserer kosmischen nachbarschaft noch
viele weitere schwerkraft giganten
dazu schreibt das forschungsteam es muss
hunderte von millionen schwarzer löcher
geben aber wir wissen nur von sehr
wenigen wenn wir wissen wonach wir
suchen müssen sollten wir besser in der
lage sein sie zu finden deshalb hält
sich ja auch weiterhin die these dass
die dunkle materie gar nicht so
existiert wie die meisten den
forschenden in der astrophysik glauben
sondern eben aus schwarzen löchern
besteht das ist nicht sehr
wahrscheinlich aber solange die dunkle
materie nicht gefunden wurde immer noch
eine option möglicherweise wurde jetzt
bereits ein weiteres dreifache system
aufgespürt so die vermutung der
fachleute in die rede ist von dem system
lb 1 das etwas weiter von der erde
entfernt ist aber astronomisch gesehen
immer noch in unserer nachbarschaft
liegt die große frage dabei können uns
solche schwarze löcher gefährlich werden
und möglicherweise sogar die gesamte
erde schlucken feststeht schwarze löcher
bringen den tod und ihr appetit kann
gigantisch sein ihr größtes talent
materie aufsaugen wenn es keine materie
rund um ihr schwerefeld gibt warten sie
geduldig ab bis sie wieder zuschlagen
können und die enorme schwerkraft dieser
massemonster sorgt dafür dass immer
wieder nahe sterne oder gaswolken in
ihre gravitations strudel geraten denn
die wirkung von gravitation ist nicht
begrenzt die wirkt immer in alle
richtungen wie wir an den
gravitationswellen sehen das heißt
schwarze löcher ziehen immer alles an
aus jeder entfernung die kraft ist weit
entfernt natürlich sehr schwach aber es
gibt sie wenn ein stern in die nähe
eines schwarzen loches gerät wird dieser
durch die enormen gezeitenkräfte
auseinandergerissen das schwarze loch
saugt es ohne erbarmen auf in der
fachsprache ist von einem so genannten
teil der destruction event die rede es
kommt zu jets aus energiereichen
teilchen gas klumpen am ereignishorizont
und strahlen ausbrüchen doch bislang
gelang es forschungsteams weltweit nur
einige male solch einen spektakulären
stern tod zu beobachten denn diese sind
sehr selten schätzungen zufolge kommen
solche teile des raschen events
in einer galaxie in der größe der
milchstraße nur einmal in 10.000 bis
100.000 jahren vor eine weitere
herausforderung für die fachleute
besteht darin solch ein ereignis
rechtzeitig aufzuspüren
bislang wurden die sterne tote erst dann
delektiert wenn der strahlen ausbruch
schon wieder ab klang und der stern
bereits zerstört war
doch könnte auch unsere erde als futter
für die gefräßige schwerkraftmonster
dienen das neu entdeckte verhältnismäßig
kleine schwarze loch tausend lichtjahre
von uns entfernt stellt wohl keine
gefahr für uns da denn selbst wenn unser
sonnensystem mit lichtgeschwindigkeit
auf ein solches schwarzes loch direkt zu
lassen würde würde es noch mehr als 1000
jahre bis zu einem zusammenstoß dauern
aber auch das ist absolut unvorstellbar
denn wir rasen nicht so schnell durch
das universum die gefahr die von
stellaren schwarzen löchern ausgeht ist
also extrem gering bei den supermassiven
schwarzen löchern allerdings könnte das
ganz anders aussehen und hier wissen wir
bereits dass die galaxie die uns am
nächsten liegt ein großes schwarzes loch
aufweist und genau mit diesem nachbarn
befindet sich unsere galaxie mitsamt der
erde auf kollisionskurs mit dem
andromeda nebel die nächste galaxie
dennoch nicht wirklich ein grund zur
aufregung den free ist ob es überhaupt
zu einer kollision mit dem schwarzen
loch selbst kommt wird sich ja
vorstellen selbst wenn zwei galaxien
kollidieren die gestirne selbst werden
nur sehr selten zusammenstoßen bei der
zwischenraum zwischen ihnen ja viel
größer ist trotzdem die gravitation wird
am ende zu einer verschmelzung der
beiden galaxien führen zudem wird das
ganze noch ewigkeiten dauern und zwar
wirklich ewigkeiten und die menschheit
wird dieses worst-case-szenario ganz
sicher nicht miterleben
es dauert noch einige milliarden jahre
was passiert in einem schwarzen loch wer
noch tiefer ins innere eines schwarzen
lochs sehen möchte der schaut am besten
bei doktor watson vorbei also hier
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
ein kanal der unbedingt empfehlenswert
ist bis dann bleibt dran